يحيون ذكرى ثورتهم الثانيه عشره في عده
مدن وبلدات شمال غربي سوريا
توجهوا الى الساحات لتجديد مطالبهم
بالحريه والكرامه واسقاط نظام السوري
يرفعون لافتات تطالب المجتمع الدولي
بالضغط على النظام السوري وحلفائه للافراج
عن الاف المعتقلين في سجونه وكشف مصيري
الاف المغيبين قصرا منذ سنوات ويطالبون
مجلس الامن بمحاسبه النظام السوري ورموزه
عن الجرائم التي ارتكبوها طيله الاعوام
الماضيه تاتي الذكرى السنويه هذا العام
لثورتهم بعد كارثه الزلزال التي ما تزال
تداعياتها مستمره حتى اليوم بعد ان قضى
اكثر من 5000 شخص وتهجر الالاف من بيوتهم
في المساعدات الانسانيه وضعف في استجابه
المنظمات الانسانيه ويطالبون ايضا
الضامنين للمسار الحل السياسي في سوريا
بايجاد حل جذريا لماساتهم ادم ابو الحسام
الجزيره مدينه ادلب